diesa the Restless is a powerful new
Commander from Modern Horizons 3 and one
of the best cards you can get for the
deck is ashes of the Fallen but there
are two major mistakes players make with
this card so let's go over the mistakes
and exactly what you can do with this
card to start let's quickly recap the
two cards daa is a five Mana 56 and the
only ability we care about for this
video is whenever a l permanent is put
into your graveyard from anywhere other
than the battlefield put it onto the
battlefield ashes of the Fallen is a two
Manor artifact from saviors of Kagawa
that says as etbs choose a creature type
each creature card in your graveyard has
the chosen creature type in addition to
its other types so with derer in play
Whenever any creature is put into your
graveyard from anywhere other than the
battlefield assuming you named lth with
ashes diesa will return it to the
battlefield effectively ashes of the
Fallen is a two Mana maswood Nexus so
here's the first mistake players make
when you have either a Ras arcade haon
or Gea and Geral in play ashes allows
you to cast the appropriately named
creature type from your graveyard to
clarify if I have ashes in play with
zombies named alongside Gesa and Geral
in play can I cast grizzly bears from my
graveyard short answer no you can't long
answer there are nine steps to Casting a
spell and while we're not going to cover
all of them in this video the two steps
that we care about in this case are the
first and fifth step the first step to
Casting a spell is to take it from its
current Zone and move it to the stack
the stack is the Zone in which spells
activated abilities and triggered
abilities wait to resolve the stack is
its own Zone just like the battlefield
and graveyard and here's where we run
into an issue ashes of the four and says
each creature card in your graveyard has
the chosen creature type in addition to
its other types so while on the stack
the creature spell loses the bonus
creature type from ashes and I know some
of you might think well it's on the
stack I should be able to cast it well
the fifth step of casting a spell
actually checks that the spell can still
be legally cast at this point and if it
can't the game returns to the moment
before
you decided to put the spell on the
stack now it's worth pointing out this
is exactly why maswood Nexus has the
text the same is true for creature
spells you control in this example if we
swapped out ashes of the Fallen with
maswood Nexus you would be able to cast
the relevant creature type from your
graveyard oh and conspiracy works here
too the next big mistake players make
with ashes of the Fallen involves dies
triggers let's say we have diagraph
captain in play which makes Target
opponent lose a life when a zombie you
control dies along with ashes of the
fallen on zombie creature type will a
grizzly bear dying trigger the captain's
ability the grizzly bear is a zombie
when it hits the graveyard so it should
trigger right well if you've been
watching this video to this point of
course you know the answer is no and
this is all thanks to time travel and
rues 6031
Z leaves the battlefield triggers or in
this case dies triggers actually look
back in time to see if they would
trigger any conditions in this case when
grizzly bear dies it looks back in time
to see if it was a zombie to trigger the
captain and once again ashes only makes
the bear a zombie when it's in the
graveyard so no the captain will not
trigger now if you learned something
from this video be sure to leave a like
and if you want to learn more things
check out this video here and be sure to
subscribe because if you don't I won't
tell you to run when the tag comes
thanks for watching and I'll see you in
the next one